je m'appelle jean-claudeinger j'ai
participé en tant que ballisticien à la
première autopsie du corps du gendarme
jeanbert on sait également que le
médecin qui a procédé la lev de corps a
déterminé une trajectoire avec un
orifice d'entrée au-dessus de la lèvre
avec une sortie temporale gauche mais
c'est tout ce qu'on sait au moment où on
procède à l'autopsie
rechercher les causes de la mort c'est
déterminer absolument tous les éléments
qui vont permettre de savoir comment
Monsieur Jambert est
mort et s'il s'est suicidé ou si a des
éléments suffisamment probants pour dire
que c'est pas lui qui s'est tiré dessus